the red carpet rolled out as a very
important guest rolls into Downing
Street the Trump's and the maze on the
steps of number 10 their last house
called together two nations whose
special relationship has endured through
a procession of different leaders but
now at a lower of these two allies
drifting apart over brexit climate
change security all that put aside at
the podium today both leaders very or
message it's the greatest alliance the
world has ever known the discussions
that we have had today are about the
future of this most important
relationship between the u.s. and the UK
as the president described it the
greatest alliance the world has seen but
the relationship between these two now
coming to an end acknowledging that
still a hard moment for mrs. may I have
greatly enjoyed working with you you are
a tremendous professional and a person
that loves your country dearly thank you
very much really an honor this No Deal
president even praised mrs. Mays brexit
deal perhaps you won't be given the
credit that you deserve if they do
something but I think you deserve a lot
of credit I really do I think you
deserve a lot of credit meanwhile down
the road the man who wants to take her
spot in number ten was addressing a
crowd opposed to President Trump we've
shown just how determined to achieve
that better place and that better world
has you hold talks with the current
prime minister the leader of Her
Majesty's opposition has been addressed
in a protest rally against your visit
what do you have to say to him and is
this man someone you could do a trade
deal with I don't know Jeremy Corbyn
never met him never spoke to him he
wanted to meet today or tomorrow and I
decided that I would not do that I think
that he is from where I come from
somewhat of a negative force I think
that the people should look to do things
correctly as opposed to criticize
I really don't like critics as much as I
like and respect people that get things
done but it won't be mr. Corbyn that he
deals with next what if the frontrunner
to succeed Mrs May as Prime Minister so
I know Boris I like him I've liked him
for a long time he's I think he'd do a
very good job
I know Jeremy I think he'd do a very
good job I don't know Michael but would
he do a good job Jeremy tell me but
whether it's Boris Johnson Jeremy Hunt
or Michael Gove they'll all have to
grapple with a president who wants to
cut a trade deal on the NHS look I think
everything with the trade deal is on the
table when you when you're dealing and
trade everything's on the table so NHS
or anything else there a lot a lot more
than that but everything will be on the
table absolutely applause in the room
but alarm outside to leadership
contenders lined up to say the NHS would
not be undermined by any post brexit
trade deal there is absolutely no way
that the NHS will be on the table for
trade talks with the United States all
with anywhere else for that matter full
stop and if I'm Prime Minister the NHS
will never be for sale not on my watch
for the US president this is a visit
about pomp pageantry and power - and
that no longer resides with mrs. May
instead he's looking at those who want
to take center stage in brexit and in
Britain granted audiences - Nigel Farrar
and senior brexit ears but who will
replace mrs. May and what it means for
the special relationship will everything
still on the table battery B Sky News
London